surprise that the country's a mess when
biden can't even keep his own white
house in order and it turns out the
source of much of the dysfunction seems
to be this person
[Laughter]
what do you want to know
i want to give you i want to give you
that a friend in need is a friend
[Music]
let's face it kamala was a disaster even
before she entered the white house her
senate career was a train wreck
it has been only a year since
kavanaugh's confirmation i was a part of
that hearing and
it's sham process i welcome everyone to
this confirmation hearing
on the nomination of mr chairman brett
kavanaugh mr chairman
uh you're out of order i'll proceed we
cannot possibly move forward mr chairman
and her failed presidential campaign was
an even bigger fiasco
well i mean listen i
this is going to sound a modest but i'm
obviously a top tier candidate and so i
did expect that i would be on the stage
and take hits tonight
now she's bringing the same energy to
the vice president's office
we've been to the border we've been to
the border you haven't been to the
border
and i haven't been to europe
i am here
standing
here on the northern flank on the
eastern flank talking about what we have
in terms of the eastern flank and our
nato allies so
ukraine is a country in europe it exists
next to another country called russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so basically that's wrong
because we have the ability to see what
can be
unburdened by what has been
and then to make the possible
actually happen talking about the
significance of the passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time
and the passage of time hasn't been kind
to her office
she lost 10 high-profile staffers
in the last nine months
the most recent of which was national
security adviser nancy mceldowney after
harris's disastrous and frankly
embarrassing trip to eastern europe last
week who could blame miss mceldowney but
the dysfunction doesn't end there
a new book by new york times reporters
jonathan martin and alex burns reveals
the growing tensions between the biden
and harris camps harris's team is
apparently bent out of shape that biden
dumped impossible tasks on her lap
but kate bettenfeld biden's coms
director reportedly had a different take
in their new book martin and burns
wright quote in private bettingfield
failed noted that the vice presidency
was not the first time in harris's
political career that she had fallen
short of sky-high expectations her
senate office had been messy and her
presidential campaign had been a fiasco
perhaps she suggested the problem was
not the vice president's staff